i only know what your vertices class
with coordinates
does fair enough yeah if you've never
seen this before
this is going to be like completely
forward
understandable this is just
opengl stuff
i want to learn this sort of stuff the
best place is probably learn
opengl.com
this walks you through all of it
like you can get super good at opengl by
just walking through all this
this was way better than my cl i had a
school and
or opengl and 3d and stuff it was okay
but this was a lot better than my class
there's a couple other sites too but i
think this is one of the better ones
i'm really only doing the very basics
here
really just testing out linux i'm out
for c
plus plus
that's harder because there's a million
different resources
i think one of the best ones though
i think trying to think of the ones that
made the biggest difference for me
i get kind of lucky and had a really
good teacher for my very first c
plus plus class so that helped
and my next class was like a million
times harder because the teacher was not
very good
but if you just want to learn c plus i
think
let me find this
there's books that are really good i'm
sure there are websites too but i'm just
not
sure like learn c plus plus
code academy i don't know i haven't
tried that one
if you want to walk through you probably
have to go to a site like one of these
they'll walk you through it
if you just want like uh
once you have the basics down
this site
this site has everything about c plus
plus you could ever want to know
so if you ever ever have a question
about what something does or what a
library does
this is all the details but as you'll
see if you're not used to see
plus plus you're not going to know what
the heck all this is
yeah this this site is like the
documentation for c
plus basically but it doesn't have a
walkthrough for learning it or anything
like that it's just like
if you already know it you want to let
go how do vectors work
you can see everything about them here
don't know about this site never used it
but
something like this would probably be
good just like
go through it real slow
yeah i would say
instead of trying to learn from your
professor
try something like one of these like if
you can manage to get through
not necessarily all this but a good
chunk of this it'll be like way ahead of
the class probably
i wish i did something like this when i
started out because
i was trying to pick up everything i
could from the structures i didn't
really know good sources but
another thing i was going to say is on
amazon
uh i just spell it john
yeah this guy the creator c plus plus he
has some really good books
this book this one helped me a ton i own
this
and i learned a ton about c plus plus
from just
going through this it's really it's like
a he just writes in a really simple way
uh i've always heard that this one is
really good too
because they basically just like walk
you through what you can do with the
language and
kind of the standard way to use it and
stuff like that
i don't know about these other ones by
other people
we probably go off the reviews and get a
pretty good idea
when i ask those people they usually say
this one but i've never
really owned this one oh that does have
a solid five stars
too 4.8 yeah this one's probably really
solid
and it's by the creator c plus plus
it's a lot of these like tutorials that
walk you through stuff
you can tell they just kind of did it to
get it done
you know until i get clicks on their
site and stuff like that sometimes
so sometimes they're not very good
but stuff like this this is like
he really cares this guy really cares
about the language and stuff
after all he did make it
cool glad i could help help you out
all right so i think i got this program
all sorted out now
let's just build it again oh
just one more error
that's not member name size
first step pause the size okay
line 17.